Donald Trump has been found liable of
sexual abuse and defamation of e Gene
Carroll he has not been found liable
when it comes to rape why am I using the
term liable I'm using the term liable
because this is a civil lawsuit and
Trump indeed these are not criminal
charges Trump will uh has been ordered
to pay five million dollars in Damages
this is a major story we've been
following for some time e Gene Carroll a
writer
alleges that alleged and alleges that
Donald Trump sexually assaulted and
raped her in the Bergdorf Goodman
Department Store in Manhattan in New
York City in the 90s the reason uh let
me even before I go further Donald Trump
in denying those accusations uh insulted
her in a number of different ways due to
a special provision that allows you to
bring a civil suit in cases of sexual
assault even when the criminal aspect
has passed its statute of limitations e
Gene Carroll was able to sue Trump
civilly in New York both for sexual
assault and for defamation and she has
prevailed we can say CNN reports a
Manhattan Federal jury found that Donald
Trump sexually abused e Gene Carroll in
a luxury department store dressing room
in the spring of 1992 six and awarded
her five million dollars for battery and
defamation
Carol alleged Trump raped her in the
Bergdorf Goodman Department Store and
then defamed her when he denied her
claim saying she's not his type and
suggested she made up the story to boost
Book Sales Trump denied all wrongdoing
he does not face jail time as a result
of the Civil verdict while the jury did
find that Trump sexually abused her
sufficient to hold him liable for
battery the jury did not find that Carol
proved he raped her so there's a bunch
of different stories that are going on
here one of the stories is Trump's
lawyer and other maggots saying Trump
prevailed
he was not found liable for rape that's
one perspective the other perspective is
Trump did not Prevail he's been ordered
to pay five million dollars for sexual
assault
and for defamation and he certainly did
not Prevail the other perspective and
we'll look at Trump's response is that
this is all just the same politically
organized weaponization of law
enforcement
that they've been saying now for years
there's no evidence of that whatsoever
everything here was handled based on
every lawyer I spoke to this morning
everything was handled perfectly by the
judge despite Trump's allegations that
the judge has it out for Trump in some
way now there is the belief that there
will be an appeal here Trump's lawyer
takapina I forget is it Joe takapina
um said that they will appeal and uh
again restated that Trump prevailed in
the sense that he was not found liable
for rape but the outcome is still quite
bad for Trump Will trump pay the five
million dollars well we don't know
certainly not before any relevant
appeals have concluded that we can be
sure of if Trump ultimately does pay
maybe he can do some of the things he's
done in the past like maybe reroute five
million dollars in I don't know campaign
donations to pay for this or something
along those lines the Maga people
already dismissing this as a listen it's
simply a civil case this isn't Criminal
it's no big deal as if suddenly civil
cases are completely irrelevant but of
course we know that that's not the case
after the break we are going to look at
the complete crumbling of trump in
response to this as well as a former
Trump White House staffer coming forward
and saying there were countless
allegations of sexual harassment against
Trump while he was President of the
United States forget about the dozens of
allegations against Trump before he
became president it turns out that there
are dozens of allegations against Trump
while he was in the white house we we
just learned about this in the last 24
hours incredible incred but not
surprising we will talk about that after
the break